what's the best advice you would give to
a business student coming from your
experience it's probably important to
and and given that I know that many
people watching this channel are
interested in Consulting it's important
to probably understand rather early
whether this is a pathway that you want
to do because surely if your goal is to
join one of the you know big leading
consulting firms you need to really move
in that direction as as fast as possible
right so I mean this has to do with
grades that you need to write so some
level of academic performance this has
to do with with some internships that
you need to make also the right Cadence
of internships